former podcast Partners St Ros hus and
Nick Mullen just put out back-to-back
comedy specials with year of the drag in
premiering on YouTube and fat Rascal
debuting on Netflix Nick Mullen special
is out on the Adam fredin show channel
we're just going to try and consolidate
and see if as you should as well
everything we need something to work and
so lisis Gomez has a special Lis J Gomez
Louis J Gomez has a special this also
holds you back making people do that
it's just if I didn't know you now I
hate you you do it on purpose no it's
just it's it's there's no other Lis
Gomez the show come toown which featured
Nick stavi and Adam Friedland was one of
the most popular podcast on patreon just
a few years ago skyrocketing the
popularity of all three Comedians and
even though they're now